[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
where we are currently off the record so
hopefully we stay off the record with
this next prompt we're about to do and
anthony goes first like always so go
ahead what's the problem yeah he goes
first i'll be good and then we have no
time left we go
the question is no nick's first would
you rather
[ __ ] your mom or [ __ ] your dad where am
i [ __ ] them
anthony will you please start it off
you're the one that brought the question
up it's a joke man we have to keep it
equal we have to keep it equal so it has
to be buttholes of both we said that was
a great idea let's do it buttholes of
both would you butt wrap your dad or
your mom it has to be equal you're it
you're in a hostage situation let me
just play rock paper scissors with nick
and then whoever loses goes first no
you're a hostage i feel like he's the
other [ __ ] of the room wait but he
doesn't have an answer prepared and he's
not the number one guy you're number one
on the contrary
give the variables and everybody has to
play by the same rule okay same rules go
ahead hostage situation
the crazy hostage guy is like you have
to [ __ ] one of them and once you're done
with [ __ ] one of them
all three of you go
all three of you go but
if you don't i kill all three of you
fine you ready
i'd [ __ ] my mom because i'm not
gay you know what i'll do one better i'd
[ __ ] my dad because there's no way i'm
gonna have sex with my mom no [ __ ]
woman in the butthole yeah no [ __ ]
way what if your mom's like i need dick
you won't do your mom in the butt
[ __ ] my dad you won't do your mom in
the butt no we wouldn't even [ __ ]
hook your mom up a little bit i'm not
crossing that line wait is this really
the prompt are we really going to do
this your turn anthony no anthony has to
go let's go anthony
the ball is your court now me and steve
answer your third on the call okay can i
make it one degree worse
the hostage guy when he makes that
announcement of what he's going to do
your mom and dad aren't in the room so
they don't know why you're trying to
[ __ ] them
yeah okay that's actually really good
that's crazy yeah all right anthony go
because it's too easy if your mom and
dad are there if my mom and dad are
there my dad would go
my dad would just go [ __ ] me i get it
yeah yeah yeah let's save mom [ __ ] the
way i'm [ __ ] like but in this
situation where they have no clue why
you're getting all touchy-feely weird
that's [ __ ] funny so your first so in
this fill in the blank worksheet anthony
question number one you have to say
which one it is yeah and then question
number two you have to talk to whichever
parent in vietnamese and we have to know
how you explain it to them that you're
gonna [ __ ] don't make it so real
you're making it so real right now and
we get to use declarative statements
declarative statements things that could
be easily snipped and taken out of
context such as i anthony lee of kenji's
shut the door
don't bring my last name into it like
that
don't do that makes it you're making it
too real because
yourself question one question
you know the parameters
[ __ ] you guys walk us through it no you
just suggested this is the answer okay
fine [ __ ] uh you got to pick who and
how how you got to say how i thought you
said it has to be in the butt well no
how are you going to get him to do it
how are you going to get you oh they
didn't [ __ ] explain how they're gonna
seduce their parents hey guess what i'm
holding my dad down dude that's it and
you can send this video to my dad and
he'd understand yeah you understand and
you could you my dad will pay for the
patreon subscription to see this video
no matter what i say you're gonna
[ __ ] hammer down on me we won't we
won't
this is a safe place safe space you prom
you're answering right after okay i was
gonna answer before you
[Laughter]
um
realistically it's probably uh it's
disgusting uh mom she's hot as [ __ ] huh
why your mom why do you think she's more
likely to buy into it why would you why
your mom instead of her dad
that's a good question yeah dude just
answer the question
don't make it what's your answer man
they're asking you a question are you
calling me the king of deflection dude
you are deflecting so hard right it's a
good thing to deflect you [ __ ]
oh that's true that is true that's a
good one
i don't know maybe it's the oedipus
complex where it's like there's there's
more of a
joe's face he's like you're making it so
real
the more he hesitates the more he's
putting it
ugh it's too serious yeah it's getting
too real now fuchsia's commentary
he who hesitated this is a guy who jerks
it to girls with huge [ __ ] that come to
the ceiling and he's judging you dude
you guys are [ __ ] ripping the walls
of my moral code down every day so
oedipus complex keep going yeah dude i
mean if anything you know what i mean
like you're freudian
if anything
it's more likely that women have taken
it in the butt than you know what i mean
my straight mama your mom actually don't
you say women
are you wearing airships [ __ ] your
mom or not
i think this is just a good question we
got to promote the air sessions dude
honestly this is horrible
to bring nike to this like that you get
you get your mom you warm up some kid's
a bag yeah what color way would you wear
joe what's your answer yeah i thought we
were gonna [ __ ] move out it's like
the [ __ ] five minute part of the
video we haven't even [ __ ] talked
about anybody else you guys you
suggested this prop dude we're just
jealous of all your products we don't
have problems oh man i don't have that
many products which kitchen would you
eat afterwards
jealous it's terrible because you're not
only having to choose which one but
you're also outing which one's more
[ __ ] yeah like which one will
actually stop making it more real joe
that's cause you're
thinking about desire i know immediately
who i'm gonna [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna hate
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of my dad's [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying thank you joe
that's a good answer
i'm gonna give him a lot of pain you
know he's not gay it's just it's a power
con and what a great way to save his
life while you're doing it and that's 37
years of build up in that answer right
there and i'm not even trying to do it
but the [ __ ] torture guy's like you
better do this or else i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you and i'm like well you know i'm
gonna [ __ ] preserve the [ __ ] out of
my mom where do you where do you go
where do you go mentally in order to
like get it hard yeah oh they give us
viagra aren't they gonna give us viagra
i don't know i can hard pretty easily
but
do you think do you think that do you
think the torture guy will be a little
bit disturbed by joe's quickness to want
to [ __ ] be like all right my dad
[Laughter]
and then the thumbnail the thumbnail is
the air sessions
and it's a picture of anthony lee biting
his lip line
why i want to [ __ ] my mom
anthony and center for 13 reasons why
you won't believe number three you won't
believe number three in hindsight you
guys are going to know the [ __ ]
reason this channel is still alive is
because of me
the leader of the king the leader of the
kingdom mr wanted a [ __ ] mom you gave
the great idea look anthony you're the
star you want to hear it you guys
telling me so hard literally my revenge
is going to be [ __ ] all your parents
go ahead and try it
have you ever just been in a classic
video before
that's me right now this is what it
feels like i'm in a classic video this
is what it feels like right now
community classes none of this will be
possible without anthony lee wow for
real can you stop saying my full name
hey what's your middle why the [ __ ]
would that happen why are you saying
he's a star so i got to say his whole
name anthony let's move on to ryan
copperito over here no harrison ford
yeah i get it yeah tom cruise tom cruise
anthony lee exactly yeah can we just
move on everybody needs a fair chance to
speak last question okay how about we
guess each other because i want to help
you i want to help you i know you're
literally the worst no because anthony i
know you're in a tough time even when
the cameras are off you're asking
questions like these no no because
you're because you're in a tough
situation and i feel bad for you now
everyone's in the same situation no but
you're you're the one that's stuck yeah
yeah because because he's like oh [ __ ]
my mom or my dad man that sucks right
like you're pick between two people that
you don't want to let's throw your
sister in there if there's three of them
now you have more choices so you're not
so in the corner you have more avenues
would you still pick your mom you want
to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of or would you
bend your sister over or would you
missionary dad
which one hey let me just make it real
easy for you
would you kiss your sister while you
[ __ ] your mom
god i'm straight in the face you guys
exactly kiss that was so perfect
that was that was that was really so
good round of applause for anthony wow
that was so good all right please stay
tuned we're about to go to an ad but
please buy this product
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you